Right.
Um,
I'd like to welcome Julia Turshen.
She's a longtime friend of mine and she's a writer and recipe developer.
In addition to her newly published solo effort,
small victories,
Julia has coauthored such bestselling cookbooks as speed a culinary road trip
with Mario Batali.
It's all good with Gwyneth Paltrow as well as mastering mistakes in the kitchen
and the Kimchi chronicles Hotbread kitchen,
the fat radish,
radish kitchen diaries and buvette.
She also hosted the first two seasons of radio,
uh,
Radio Cherry bomb,
which is a podcast.
Um,
and Julia is famous for using simple techniques to demonstrate how small
victories in the kitchen can help you become a confident cook.
So we are very excited to have her here at Google to show us all how it's done.
With that,
I'll hand it over to Julia.
Thanks Karen.
Um,
I think Karen left out.
She said we're old friends,
but Karen's my oldest friend,
we met in the third grade.
Um,
and we've been friends ever since.
So this is just great to be here and it's full circle.
Um,
and I'm just so happy to meet all of you.
So I have this new book,
small victories,
which I think you're all going to get a copy at the end.
It came out yesterday.
I'm super excited about it.
This is my first time talking about it,
um,
in front of anyone but a mirror.
This is awesome.
Um,
so I thought I'd tell you a little bit about the book and a little bit about the
recipe that I'll demonstrate and then we can eat some of the recipe.
And I would love to answer any questions you guys might have.
So my first question is how,
see if I worked at Google,
I don't think I would maybe ever cook cause you guys have such amazing food,
but how many of you cook at home?
Oh,
that's awesome.
Okay,
cool.
so I'm talking to her home cooks.
That's great.
So small victories,
the title is the same as just the whole concept of the cookbook.
And it's basically approaching food,
sort of thinking about small victories,
which I think of as like tips or techniques that make cooking really
approachable.
Um,
really let you be like an intuitive cook.
and just make it really fun.
And so every recipe in the book is introduced by like a small victory,
which is this tip or technique.
And then every recipe's followed by a bunch of spinoffs,
which are like variation.
So once you know the tip or technique,
you can make the thing,
but you can also make x,
Y,
and z.
So it's sort of thinking about cooking and this very exponential way,
which I feel like is kind of,
to me,
there's some sort of synthesis with everything you guys do at Google.
And it's like this one thing,
but it can be so many other things.
Um,
so I was going to demonstrate the Turkey and ricotta and meatballs today,
which are,
um,
honestly I feel like choosing a favorite recipe from the book.
It's like asking someone to choose their favorite kid or something.
Like I just,
I can't,
but this might be it.
And,
um,
there are especially special to me because they were the first thing I made for
my wife,
grace.
And she had,
um,
told me about,
she had just recently,
right before we met,
she had eaten these.
Um,
I think the reveal and ricotta me balls at a restaurant,
she said they were so great and I was like,
oh my God.
Like I love this girl,
I want to impress her.
So I was like,
I'm going to try to make something.
And um,
so I,
the thing I ever brought to her apartment,
which became our,
our apartment was,
um,
my pot.
So that's what I brought over and I made her these meatballs.
And anyway,
we got married really soon after.
So I feel like I,
I don't promise,
you know,
lifelong love or marriage,
but it worked for me,
so I highly recommend it.
Um,
so we,
um,
yeah,
I mean whatever,
like I can't hurt.
Right.
Um,
so that sort of small victories in this recipe or a few one is that I,
um,
the meatballs are really simple and they don't take that many ingredients.
And I'm going to combine Turkey with ricotta because as my mother in law
recently said to me,
cause she made these,
um,
Turkey let's face it is always dry.
Um,
but it's,
you know,
it's a nice sort of leaner,
healthier option.
And I think adding ricotta too,
it makes them just not dry and really sort of succulent in this great way.
And in a way that sort of beef and pork can be that Turkey isn't always.
Um,
and it also happens to make the meatballs totally gluten free if that's
important to you or the people you were cooking for.
Cause you can,
by adding the ricotta you can skip the eggs and bread crumbs that are normally
in meatballs,
which was kind of Nice.
And um,
then I just pack them with a bunch of herbs we're going to make them.
And then the simplest tomato sauce and the other small victories that I baked
the meatballs instead of pan frying them.
Cause it's just so much easier.
It's a lot less mess.
You're not like cleaning up like a spattered stovetop and everything.
Um,
so those are some of the small victories.
And then in the book you'll see you can turn,
once you know how to make these meatballs,
you can take those techniques and make so many different kinds.
So actually my wife grace runs this amazing website design sponge.
And this week I'm doing all these posts on lunchbox meals.
So yesterday we did like a Turkey Merguez meatball with like cumin and Heresa
and flavors like that.
So if you change the ingredients or you know,
change the sauce,
you can really have this whole other thing.
So it's,
it's just great.
So I'm going to start mixing them,
but then I was hoping maybe to get a couple of volunteers to help me roll them.
But first I'm gonna wash my hands,
but if there's anyone who might be interested in rolling them,
you can also,
there's sinks there.
You can use this one.
Um,
we've got some gloves if you'd like,
but um,
I'll just walk you through them because they're super easy.
I also love meatballs because you can,
um,
make a huge batch of them and keep them going for a while.
And all the recipes in the book,
I'm just going to throw that right there.
All the recipes in the book for the most part,
just serve for people.
Um,
but this one I purposely did a double batch because I always make extra so I
figured most people would want to because who doesn't want meatballs in the
fridge at any point?
So it starts with just ground Turkey.
I'm,
I definitely prefer dark meat for this.
Um,
just cause it's got a lot more fat and moisture and those things that just make
them taste really good.
And then we have um,
ricotta cheese,
which is just whole milk ricotta cheese.
I'm just going to add that.
And then it really helps if you have someone like Marianne who's going to chop
up everything for you.
There is,
it makes it super easy.
I highly recommend that.
Um,
and then we're going to do this is just chopped fresh parsley and um,
I love it cause it's,
you know,
gives them a lot of flavor but also color.
Um,
and they look nice and fresh.
This is chopped Bazell at all of it.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's all a portion.
Awesome.
I have to take you everywhere.
I'm so excited.
Um,
and then this is some grated Parmesan,
which I'm putting in them and we'll also put on them later because it just makes
everything better.
So why not put it in and on top?
Because life is short and it should be full of cheese and some chopped fresh
garlic,
same thing and um,
some salt.
So I just washed my hands for probably like the fifth time today.
And um,
I think hams were the best tool for this job.
So I just mix it with my hands.
But if you're kind of like,
I'm not so into touching like raw meat,
you can totally just do this with,
you know,
one big mixing spoon.
Um,
and that is literally it.
Like that's all you need to do to make this mixture.
And then we're just going to roll them into,
I like to do kind of like golf ball sized meatball.
Hi,
Jenny Posen.
How are you?
Um,
and um,
but you can make them really like small,
like little,
um,
like Pulpa teeny or you can make larger ones like a big softball size me.
Well if you want,
I guess that gets you into meat loaf territory,
but it's nothing wrong with that.
So as you can see,
they have a lot of,
you know,
there's sort of as green as they are pink.
And I just,
I love having that many fresh herbs and anyway,
so is anyone interested in rolling?
Yeah.
Oh,
awesome.
Amazing.
Okay.
This is going to go really fast.
So if you guys want to come up here,
um,
one thing that Maryann took out,
which I love,
is that ice cream scoop.
Um,
and that means you can get really evenly sized,
um,
meatballs,
which is awesome,
but you can also just kind of free form it.
They don't have to be like super perfect.
I'm a big fan of food that's like not totally perfect.
I really just,
I love homemade stuff just in general and in theory.
So anyway,
so if you guys want to help me out,
we can,
um,
can use this or just,
you know,
do it about that size.
Yeah.
Go for it.
And yeah,
go for it.
And um,
and we'll roll them out and put them here.
Yeah,
you can use that if you'd like.
Um,
and maybe while you guys are willing those out,
I'm going to walk you through the tomato sauce that after we bake the meatballs,
they're going to just simmer in the sauce.
You can also,
um,
like I've,
my really close friend Larry,
he has like,
I hope he doesn't mind me saying this,
he's got like bad,
like acid reflux kind of stuff.
Like a lot of people have that so you can skip the sauce,
you can just make the meatballs,
eat them on their own.
They're delicious.
There's a lot of flexibility.
I really feel like recipes,
like they tend to be sort of seen as and treated as kind of prescriptions.
Like you have to do this exact thing.
And I totally don't believe that.
I feel like you can make them anything.
It's your,
it's your kitchen,
it's your meal,
make it work for whatever your needs are.
Um,
but I love tomato sauce and I think they're delicious in it.
So we're gonna make this and it's honestly like,
just,
it'll take like 10 seconds and don't blink because you'll miss it.
Cause it's super simple.
So I'm just going to turn this on.
Did I do it right?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Okay,
great.
And then all it is is a little bit of olive oil
and then this is um,
perfectly sliced garlic cause I didn't slice it.
And once this gets a little bit hot,
I'm going to add this in the oil.
Kind of like,
I always think of it,
it kind of like Bloom's the garlic.
It starts to sizzle and it just gets all that great flavor.
If I'm going to let it get hot so it can do that.
And then we're going to add,
these are can hold tomatoes.
Um,
which I like to crush before just so you don't get like a huge tomato.
But um,
if you like really smooth sauce,
you could run them through a blender or use like an immersion blender or a food
mill,
you know,
whatever device you have.
Um,
but I kind of like,
again,
like the sort of imperfect perfect meatballs.
Like I like a little bit of texture in the sauce.
So I like to just crush them with a hand with my hands and put them in a big
bowl.
And that's,
I don't know if any of you have kids or are thinking about it or are on your way
like Erin,
but,
um,
it's a really great job for kids to do,
like to get in a big bowl of tomatoes and like crush them.
It feels like,
oh my God,
I get to make a mess and,
but like it's for a good purpose.
So that's always great.
So this seems nice and hot.
This is way better than my stove at home.
Um,
so I just added that garlic and I think you guys can see,
I'm not sure,
but,
um,
I'll face it this way.
I only,
when I add garlic to oil in a pan,
I always kind of tilt the pot so that the garlic can kind of like fry in it.
Um,
and obviously if you had a ton of olive oil,
you wouldn't need to do that.
But this way you don't have to add like so much faff to what you're making.
So just kind of get it till it's like really nice and fragrant and this to me is
just the best smell in the world.
I don't think there's really much better than that.
Oh my God,
they did it.
That's amazing.
Okay,
so we're going to add the tomatoes and just maybe not where like your favorite
white shirt when you do this.
That's my only advice and those go in and I am just going to add a bit of salt
and tomatoes definitely love salt.
So don't be shy.
And basically this comes to a boil and once it does that I'm going to turn the
heat down a little bit.
And that is tomato sauce.
So tomato sauce is something a lot of people buy in a jar.
It usually is like filled with sugar and preservatives and all this stuff.
Fine if you like those things.
But if you don't,
it's really like to me this is the most delicious sauce and it's really that
easy and this is something that you can make a big batch of.
It freezes really well.
If you're into like DIY stuff,
you can migrate tomatoes right now at the farmer's market in New York,
peel them,
you know,
make your own sort of canned tomatoes.
Um,
but that's it.
And it's as simple as that.
So these are going to go in the oven and that's how they'll cook.
I love those who made the little one.
It's so cute.
It was great.
Um,
the only thing I'm going to do before I put them in the oven,
it's just drizzle them with a little bit more olive oil on top because basically
fat helps things.
Brown,
um,
also makes things delicious.
So I'm a little olive oil will help and there's,
um,
I forgot to mention there's olive oil rubbed on a piece of parchment on this
pan,
which again,
we'll just help them release.
Basically anything that makes your life easier in the kitchen is great by me.
So that's the purpose of that.
It also makes clean up easier cause we don't have like that burned like Turkey
stuff on the pan once it's done.
So a little drizzle
and then we're going to race these and then once they're cooked,
we'll pop them in the tomato sauce.
Okay.
Awesome.
So I'm going to stick them in here.
I think we're at four 25,
which is,
um,
I feel like a temperature.
I tend to do a lot of things at and um,
we're going to cook them for,
um,
I can't remember how long.
I think like 20,
25 minutes.
But you just sort of check them.
I'm going to check this to see what I told you because let's see if I'm right.
Oh Yeah,
about 25 minutes.
That's good.
And,
but I'll probably check them around 20 and since we have two trays in 10
minutes,
I'm just going to flip them just so they cook really nice and evenly.
And then we'll pop them in here.
And those are Turkey and Maconomy balls and they're one of my favorite things
and I hope you enjoy them.
And so that you don't have to wait for 20 minutes.
We have some already cooked and they're bubbling away right by Deborah.
Um,
and we also have some pasta because I just feel like there's nothing better than
meat balls on Spaghetti,
but these are also something that like,
I love like a big bowl of like something like,
like really garlic Lee Garlicky,
Broccoli rob next to a pile of meat balls.
It's like a little healthier.
It's a little lighter if you're,
you know,
trying to avoid things like carbs,
but if you're not,
then you can just eat this all to yourself,
which is what I would love to do.
Um,
and they're also really delicious on Polenta or rice.
anything that's going to help absorb that sauce is really like,
it's going to be your friend here and maybe like a piece of garlicky toast or
something like that.
But I really feel like if you know how to make these,
you just like,
it means you have this really great like home cook thing in your fridge waiting
for you when you get home from work.
You guys all work like super hard.
You work at one of the busiest places and I feel like taking the time to make
something homemade,
just,
it's a really,
I think it's a sort of like empowering thing to do and it's like it's a nice
kind of self care moment or you know,
great for your family.
So those are the main boss.
So I would love,
maybe we could have people try them if that works out.
And um,
oh yeah.
And I would love to know if you have any questions about meatballs,
cookbooks,
um,
anything.
Yeah,
please.
Yeah.
When you made it before,
like you,
you kind of crushed it beforehand.
Did you add anything special to that?
Like any herbs or nothing exactly into the meatball.
Sometimes I like to like,
um,
that moment when you add the tomatoes to the hot sort of garlicky oil.
Sometimes I like to throw like one or two whole sprigs of fresh basil,
just the whole thing,
like you don't even take off and just let it cook as the sauce cooks and then I
pull it out at the end and it gives like a really nice flavor.
But you can,
I mean if you want other herbs like you could put like finely chop time or
rosemary,
any of those kinds of like woody herbs and this sauce also can go in a lot of
different directions.
Like if I'm making like those sort of north African meatballs I was talking
about like with the acumen and stuff.
Sometimes like I'll put a cinnamon stick in the oil and then add the tomatoes
and it like it's one ingredient but it makes it this whole different thing and
it just gives us this whole new level like layer of flavor.
So that's a really nice thing to do.
But this is kind of like the baseline and then you can go anywhere.
I have one more question.
Yeah,
please.
Yeah.
If you're not going to like kind of professionally canning jar.
Yeah,
don't need to do that.
Yeah.
How long would that stay?
Good.
I would say what state good for.
Definitely at least like a week in the fridge.
And if you don't want to do the canning and jarring and stuff,
I highly recommend just putting it like in a quart size Ziploc or you know,
whatever brand of plastic baggy like and um,
and then freeze it.
And when I do,
I do that with soups a lot and tomato sauce and I put it in the bag and then I
lay it flat in the freezer.
And then once it's frozen you can kind of stack them up and make like files.
So you can have your like super sauce filing cabinet in the freezer.
It takes up like a lot less space,
which is a premium in New York.
Um,
and it just,
it makes it really easy.
Also,
you can do it in a smaller size bag and then you can pull out,
like if you're just cooking for yourself or just one or two other people,
like you don't have to defrost like this huge thing just to get like a little
bit.
So yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
Thank you.
But those of us who don't cook,
um,
come over.
What do you recommend starting with?
What are some good recipes to be in?
That's a great question.
I think this is a really good recipe.
It mostly just because they're delicious and they're like pretty easy to make
and you can make such a big batch.
As I was talking about,
um,
I think I may have,
I know it's on,
sorry.
There's also,
it really depends on what you like to eat.
I think if you,
um,
you know,
if you enjoy chicken,
there's a roast chicken,
um,
in small victories,
which is kind of like there's a roast chicken in every cookbook.
I know.
But this one I really believe in so much cause it sort of teaches you all these
great techniques that aren't techniques.
They're just easy at me.
Like I'm thinking about taking the chicken out so it's at room temperature
before it goes in the oven.
So you're not putting this ice cold thing in a hot oven.
And like likewise one of those cooking.
So it's like doing a simple thing like that.
We'll make a big difference.
Um,
it's got a really nice mix of like salt and Rosemary and lemon and garlic and
just all the things you want with a roast chicken.
So that's a really great place to start.
And I feel like roasting a chicken has kind of like pick,
if he can do that in the kitchen to get started,
it makes you feel like you can kind of do anything.
Um,
but if you're vegetarian,
obviously don't roast the chicken cause you,
that would probably make you really bummed out.
Um,
so yeah,
it really totally depends on what you want to eat.
But I would say those two are my favorite starting points.
Hey,
yeah,
space is a premium.
So my,
yes,
it's about just one 30th the size of it.
Do you have any small victories or strategies or,
for sure,
really tiny.
So I,
I'm so I now live in upstate New York.
Um,
we kind of live in the middle of nowhere and I now have a big kitchen.
But prior to that I lived in a series of studio apartments in New York and very
rarely had accounters.
You know,
space like this to me is a lot of space.
I didn't have that for a long time.
Um,
but I have worked on cookbooks and I've tested cookbooks in apartments with that
kind of counter.
So I've done a lot of cooking and really small spaces.
Um,
I think a few things.
One,
a folding table is an awesome thing and I have set up many in um,
you know,
whatever spaces near my kitchen when I'm doing a lot of cooking because I think
you don't really need much more space than this.
Like you can't chop much more than this at a time.
But my problem was always like,
oh,
I cut up,
you know,
these onions or whatever,
I'm putting them in a bowl to use and then where do I put that bowl?
So like having that extra space somewhere,
the top of the fridge is a really nice spot for that.
But I think having a small space really forces you to be organized.
And to me,
cooking in New York was all about kind of shopping for just what I needed for
that specific thing.
And not getting overwhelmed with,
you know,
so much on the counter or anything.
Um,
and I think the other thing is like,
I'm,
I mean,
I love a blender.
I love,
you know,
I love a gadget here or there,
but I really don't think they're all that necessary.
I honestly think if you have like a few good mixing goals and a pot and a good
knife,
like you can make anything and like,
I don't think you need that many gadgets or electronics like on the kitchen
counter.
So that would be my advice.
It's just to kind of pair down and you can make a lot.
So.
Any other questions when you tell us more about how you got into this field?
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
so I have cooked since,
um,
like,
well before I can remember.
I can't,
I like truly can't remember a time when I wasn't cooking.
When I met Karen when we were eight,
I was already into food.
Um,
and I have just always loved it.
It's been my passion.
Um,
and the thing,
I've also really loved his writing and I always loved English classes.
Um,
and my parents both worked in publishing,
so it always felt very familiar and comfortable to me to be near magazines and
books and sort of printed matter.
Um,
which is fascinating to be here at Google,
but I always loved combining my love of food with my love of writing.
Um,
and at whatever age when you start writing like book reports,
like Middle School,
that kind of like I like I wrote about like what huck Finn Eight,
like it was always about food.
I was always writing about food.
Um,
and then I went to college in New York on the upper west side.
I went to Barnard.
And being in New York,
as you all know,
kind of gives you this sort of entry point to lots of things that you might not
have access to in other places.
So I started interning.
I was an internet food and wine magazine for a year.
I worked for this great guy who produces food shows for um,
public television.
I just kind of got my foot in as many food doors as I could and then worked
really hard to stay on the other side of those doors.
Um,
and the guy who produced the produced all that public television shows,
he worked on that show,
Spain on the road again.
Um,
and you mentioned the first book I worked on was called Spain and culinary road
trip,
which was the companion book to that show.
Um,
and so that was really my starting point and then it was kind of one thing led
to another.
And My,
I feel like the best way I can describe my career is that I've never written a
resume.
It's all word of mouth,
it's all sort of personal relationships.
And to me that's kind of the spirit of food.
It's like about sharing,
you know,
just these great things with other people.
So that's,
that's been that.
It's a fun road.
Oh,
hey.
So you mentioned meeting your wife through a meatball recipe.
Any other fun date night recipes?
Shit work.
You excited?
Yeah,
I think,
um,
that's so funny.
Um,
so I'm trying to think like I think one really great thing to do is to cook
together.
If both you and the person you are,
you know,
having a romance with enjoy cooking,
um,
that can be really fun to just kind of have an activity and then you're like,
you're making something together that's really nice and it's nice to sit down
and be like,
oh we both like invested this time and to doing that,
um,
you know,
you can both row out the meatballs like whatever works and,
but also if the person you're with doesn't enjoy cooking,
it really can be such a gift to cook for someone.
Or if you don't really like cooking you can just kind of like gently push a
cookbook during their way.
Um,
and you know,
make a suggestion of maybe they like cooking.
Cause I think cooking is just the best way to show someone you really care about
them.
It's been my means of doing that my whole life.
And it can be simple.
It can be like a sandwich that someone takes,
you know,
to the office.
Like,
I really believe cooking doesn't have to be over the top to be just meaningful
by any means.
Um,
so some good things to make it home.
There's a recipe in small victories for if you like fish.
It's a really easy recipe and it's basically you take a sheet pan,
like the one we had the meatballs on and you put um,
either chopped tomatoes or cherry tomatoes,
a little garlic and oil roasted and make this kind of roasted tomato like base.
And then you put some,
like,
I use flounder in the book,
but any kind of flat thin fish that will cook sort of quickly.
And you put that on top of the roasted tomatoes.
You put like a little bit of olive oil and I put some olives because I loved
them,
but we'll leave them out and you just put that back in the oven and it takes
like 10 minutes and it's like this,
it's really like,
it's kind of like a really elegant dish,
but it's so easy and it's like you're not dealing with like searing fish in a
hot pan and it's gonna overcook and it's gonna make your apartment smell like a
seafood restaurant for a week.
And,
um,
there's also another fish that's wrapped in parchment and has something called
Chermoula,
which was the sort of north African kind of,
sort of like a pesto.
It's got like Cilantro and cumin and those kinds of flavors.
That's really nice because again,
you're not dealing with like smoky fish stuff in a small space.
Um,
and those two are like pretty quick to put together and kind of just like a
little bit elevated.
Like,
I dunno,
making fish at home always feels like a little special to me.
So I like for a date kind of thing.
That would be great.
And,
um,
if you don't like fish,
I just,
I really always go back to the roast chicken.
I just think it's the best.
I'll ask one more,
uh,
cause like I suppose you don't always eat your own food.
Do you have any favorite restaurants in New York City?
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
my friend Mario Batali who I know is coming to do an event,
I think at some point.
Um,
he has a line that I love,
which is his favorite thing to eat is anything anyone else makes.
So I totally get that.
Um,
my,
now that I don't live in the city when I,
it's sort of helped me feel very clear about the places I do love to come to
because my time here is much more limited than it used to be.
And honestly,
the three restaurants I love more than anything or very close by.
Um,
their buvette via Carota and East Sodi and Buvette.
full disclosure,
I worked on the buvette books.
I'm totally biased.
Um,
but so happily,
uh,
biased and Jody Williams runs buvette.
She's amazing.
She's one of the funniest people in the world.
She's so talented.
It's a little,
if you haven't been there,
it's tiny.
It's nothing like Google.
It's this big.
Um,
and it's basically like stepping into like a little slice of Paris.
It's really special.
It's like a very sort of,
you feel transported,
which is I think one of the best things you can feel in a restaurant.
And you can go there anytime a day,
which was great.
So you can get like a little breakfast or just a coffee.
You can have a full meal if you want.
I just think it's really special.
And then,
um,
Jodi's partner in life and business runs is Sodi,
which I think,
I hate to tell a big group this because it's already hard to get into,
but I think it's the best restaurant in New York.
It's the most amazing Italian restaurant.
It's on Christopher Street.
And then together they run via Carota on Grove Street.
And I just think they put their heart into everything they do and they just kind
of embodied the spirit of hospitality.
They really make you feel taken care of and their food is just delicious.
So those are my three go tos and you can go to all of them in one night because
they were all right there.
Any other questions?
What do you think of the meatballs?
Good.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Okay,
cool.
That's great to hear.
That's great.
Huh?
I have a good Google strike.
Is it okay if I tell that?
Because I was thinking about coming here and ways,
cause I was talking about like loving print so much,
but also like Google has really changed my life as a cookbook author.
And I'm not just saying that.
And one of the ways I was thinking that has happened is um,
I'm really bad with time,
but I guess a couple of years ago is working on,
and maybe it came out a year or two ago,
a book called,
um,
the hot bread kitchen cookbook and hot bread kitchen is this amazing
organization.
It's like a workforce development program.
It's based in Harlem.
They sell it,
the farmer's markets and um,
whole foods in New York,
all different places.
They supply some restaurants.
It's a wholesale bakery,
but it's completely employed by sort of immigrant and low income women.
And they get on the job training.
They also get business,
um,
classes,
English as second language classes,
all that kind of amazing staff.
And they're basically graduated from the program to go on to take management
positions and other bakeries and sort of,
you know,
cooking places in New York,
um,
or start their own businesses,
which is awesome.
And when I was,
oh,
the other great part about it is they,
everything they make is inspired by the women or recipes or contributed by them.
So they have the most sort of eclectic,
interesting,
amazing roster of things that they make like the best Jewish,
Hala and Bialys,
but they also make like incredible tortillas and Moroccan flatbreads.
Like they're amazing.
So when I was working on that book,
it was sort of me communicating with all these different women trying to get
their recipes written,
trying to get,
you know,
all these stories down.
And there was definitely at certain points,
a real language barrier and it's kind of amazing how much you can communicate
with food without actually talking.
So that was like an interesting,
but I like could not have done that book without Google translate and I am so
grateful for it.
And to me it was such an interesting moment of like,
wow,
this like this is making this so possible.
And it was so clear to me in that moment when I was on my way here today.
I was just like,
Dang,
that would be a good story to tell here.
So thank you.
Whoever works on translate.
Oh my God,
that's amazing.
I feel like this is good if you run,
I mean like I've heard about carbo loading and stuff.
So
anyway,
any other questions?
Yes.
Thank you
for coming by the way.
This is amazing.
Oh,
I'm so glad you like that.
Um,
I was interested,
you've obviously worked with a lot of a really famous chefs whose,
um,
who would be somebody that you haven't worked with yet that you'd be really
interested in?
Oh,
I'm running with in the future.
That's a great question.
Um,
I would think about this for a second.
There's a few,
there's a few that come to mind and they're both in the south.
Um,
and my wife,
grace we were talking about is from Virginia.
So there's,
there's part of me that like,
it feels very drawn towards the south.
Maybe it's from that.
Um,
but one does not need my help whatsoever.
and her name is Vivian Howard.
She a PBS show.
Um,
she has her own book.
I think it's coming out in October.
It's amazing.
Um,
I got to see a little sneak peek of it,
but I think her approach to food is just,
it's so,
um,
from the heart and she's just such a talented chef on top of that sort of really
deep emotional connection to food.
So I guess maybe I wouldn't want to work with her cause I don't think she needs
that.
But I guess I would just like to spend more time with her.
Um,
and the other is this great guy.
can,
I don't really know,
but I had one conversation with him.
His name is Ed Mitchell and he is,
uh,
based in North Carolina.
And I don't know if any of you read or watch the,
um,
I guess Netflix version maybe of Michael Pollan's cooked.
Um,
and he,
Michael spent a lot of time with Ed Mitchell and Ed Mitchell does whole heart,
whole hog barbecue,
which was hard to say,
um,
in North Carolina.
And he learned from his father and his grandfather and it's passed down and he
just,
I feel like he has so many amazing stories to tell.
Um,
and I think those stories are so,
and I think a cookbook is a great place to store those kinds of stories and a
way to just be able to interact with them too.
Because not only do you get to tell them,
like I got to tell you about like,
oh,
I met grace and I fell in love and I made her meatballs.
But also like,
here you can make meat balls to it.
So I feel like Ed has these really incredible stories that are just so much
about his family,
but also kind of the history of America and it's,
they're important.
So I think,
I hope those get written down now.
Of course.
Hey.
Okay.
Do you have any foods that you hate working with?
Ah,
hate working with,
but you know there are fan favorites.
Ah,
okay.
You have to work with them anymore.
Right.
Question.
Um,
I really like,
okay.
I feel like I don't really dislike any food.
Um,
and grace was poking fun at me yesterday cause I can't even remember what I was
eating and I was like,
Oh God,
I love this as the best thing I ever had.
And she was like,
you say that about everything.
Everything's the best thing you'll ever have.
So I really,
there's not much I don't like,
but I guess I feel like the thing I do try to avoid and try to avoid using in
recipes but also just eating is just like super processed food.
Just things like I don't really understand.
Um,
and I definitely have a soft spot for like a cool ranch,
Doritos or something like that.
But like I feel like those are the kinds of products I try not to use.
And also it just comes from,
I feel very strongly about writing recipes that anyone can replicate no matter
where they are.
And asking for a very particular brand of something.
And something I always try not to do unless I really have a reason for doing
that.
And if I do,
I'll always give you like a substitution because just because you know it's hard
in New York cause he can find anything.
But in a lot of places you can't.
So,
but I would say anything like super,
super processed.
Okay.
Any other questions?
No.
Cool.
Well this was super fun and I hope you guys try to meat balls and maybe try some
variations.
And I guess the only thing I forgot to mention is my sort of fantasy with small
victories and offering all the variations and riffs on the recipes is,
I can't wait to see what people make.
But like,
you know,
it's inspired by the rest of it,
but isn't the recipe like I just,
I feel like I put,
I tried to be as creative as I possibly could,
but I think there's something about cookbooks and how people participate with
them and try them on their own,
that makes it,
this kind of collaborative things.
So if you have any other ideas for meatball riffs that I love to know them.
Oh,
Hashtag hashtag small victories cookbook.
That's it.
Cool.
Thank you all so much.